my name is Nora West Allen and I'm the
fastest woman alive when I was a child
my father disappeared and something
impossible then I grew up and became the
impossible hey everybody it's Charlie
this is gonna be my flash episode one
video they swung for the fences with
their references so there's a crazy
number of Easter eggs
so we'll do top 10 and I'll try to
keep the video from going too long just
because there's so much we need to talk
about because they did the flash ring of
course there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
flash related comment on the video
starting with number 10 we get Nora's
intro narration where we would normally
get the Barry intro and if you've ever
watched my hero academia it's a little
bit like Deku doing his opening
narration this is the story of how I
became the greatest hero in the world
even though Nora is a flash she says
that she's not that good she doesn't
have all the skills that Barry has so
sure she's aspiring to be better
number 9 Nora initially says that her
big quote/unquote mistake was helping
Barry blow up the satellite suddenly I
can't go home but the thing about that
is is that later she admits to lying
about that so even if it was one of her
big mistakes I think that there's
something else going on or they're just
using it as a red herring there are a
lot of other things that they'll do on
accident that will lead to Secada
beating them in the future when he
shouldn't have in the original timeline
that was why Wally had that big
explainer at the end of the episode
where he said there are fixed moments in
time that you can't change and then
there are some moments that are okay to
change so just remember that they're
gonna keep referencing messing up the
timeline for the first couple of
episodes I'm sure mostly for comedy like
please don't give us spoilers about
what's going to happen they make a bunch
of time-travel references stepping on
her butterfly is a reference to the
story a sound of thunder Marty McFly
Back to the Future Terminator 2 but they
go to great lengths to let you know that
Nora is who she says she is she has both
Barry and iris as DNA and they spent a
couple of conversations between her and
Barry between her and iris about what it
means for her to be there and why she
came back and why it's so important that
she get to meet her father so I think
that's their way of killing all the Nora
is lying about who she is theories like
she's not the fanboy younger version of
reverse-flash pretending
to be nora number aid Barry gets
reinstated as a CSI letting you know
that he's gonna be doing a lot more sure
locking that's why captain's saying told
him there's a backlog of cases meaning
that he's gonna be buried in work for
most of the least the first half of the
season maybe the back half - Nora speeds
in it gives you more of her backstory
I'm a CSI just like you I went to the
same school like they just want to let
you know that she's almost exactly like
her father she idolizes him
they finished each other's sentences
they have the joke about the cookie
dough and you start to get the over
eager Nora like she rushes and grabs his
season one suit from Cisco's Closet in
an instant fan favorite oh gee flash
suit which they then you know pay off
when he's helping save the guards from
gridlock another fun moment - is Nora
saying that she has a 5.6 GPA when 4.0
is supposed to be perfect inside the
United States even if she's really naive
and she's making a lot of mistakes she's
kind of like Jessie quickened that she's
crazy smart but not necessarily the best
speedster that they can be yet number
seven the big flash museum name-drop so
this is just Nora explaining how she
learned all about the flash I studied
everything about your history fun fact -
this is almost exactly like the reverse
flashes back story he was an expert on
all things flash in the speedforce
he was even curator of the flash Museum
further in the future so remember Nora
is from about 30 years in the future
reverse flash is still from hundreds of
years in the future so even though there
are a lot of reverse flash Easter eggs
buried in there
they still want to let you know that
Nora is Nora Nora name-drop Lightning
Lad who's a member of the Legion of
super-heroes from a way further in the
future so I'm assuming the heat
time-traveled back and that's when he
met Nora but the use all that awkward
coffee talked to sort of set up the
ongoing drama between her and iris oh
yeah you know mom's off doing her own
thing in the future yeah she's doing
fine the writers didn't say what it was
that was so awkward between them and why
Nora isn't so hot on her but they did
say that they would resolve that within
the first couple of episodes so it's not
like it's gonna stretch across the
entire season the shui slang term that
she keeps using is them doing the Bart
Allen thing where he just says crash the
mode all the time so most of you
probably picked up that the energy with
which she entered the frame and she was
introducing herself to everyone was very
much like Bart Allen
especially on Young Justice so it's sort
of their way of doing the Bart Allen
character without actually doing Bart
Allen so like she name drops all those
characters from the future like Ryan
Choi she didn't say anything about Bart
Allen or having a brother so with just
them leaving themselves room if they
want to do those characters later they
could change the timeline this season
and then by the end of the season it
turns out she does have a twin brother
in the future so they could get to
tornado twins in a roundabout way but
original Nora is an only child
number six though the negative tachyons
it felt like this was their reference to
the negative Speed Force even though
that's not exactly how the negative
Speed Force works the negative Speed
Force was something that was originally
created by the reverse-flash but then
later comics sort of retcon that a
little bit so these are just winking at
that from behind the camera without
necessarily paying themselves down so
I've always wondered if they were gonna
use that as a concept number five we get
the big bomb from the future newspaper
Barry asked Nora she explains what
happens to him not necessarily how he
dies but that he never comes back so
this is right out of crisis on Infinite
Earths in the comics so what happens is
Barry turns into pure speed force energy
and doesn't Rema t realize until flash
rebirth but like Nora says see this is
actually really accurate he never comes
back in the future that's because when
he came back he came back in the past
now there been a bunch of retcons
originally what happened is is when he
died in this crisis moment he turned
into the lightning bolt that gave him
his Speed Force powers so his life
became this loop and it was Wally West
who was the first person to encounter
his children the tornado twins when he
became the main version of the flash
they actually mistook him for their
father are you our dad no I'm Wally West
I'm the other flash the way Nora
explains it she was born a couple years
quote-unquote before this crisis event
so that's the writers also saying that
we're not gonna tell you exactly when
she's born so that you don't know when
we're gonna get iris pregnant and
they're gonna have that baby so maybe
sometime in the next couple of seasons
they've teased it who knows what they're
gonna do with that number for Nora gives
him the flash costume ring it looks
exactly like the effect in the comic
book does it turns out it was made by
Ryan Choi who is the second version of
the atom in the comics he became the
atom after ray Paul
disappeared after identity crisis
because he was so grief-stricken so who
knows maybe we'll get Ryan choy on one
of the TV shows in the next couple of
seasons I would assume that they would
do that character either on flash or on
legends of tomorrow because Ray Palmer
is on legends of tomorrow but number
three they phase the plane it's right
out of the beginning of the new 52 flash
comic book title they phase all the
people out of the plane and crash it
right in the bay it's totally cool it
looked like it was right off of the page
and Barry gives her the reverse flash
Harrison wells speech from season one
exactly
they even spliced footage in from season
one so it's sort of their way of
referencing season one energy they want
to get back to the tone of season one
the balance of humor in drama and give
the energy of Barry being really excited
about stuff because he's so excited
because his daughter is here while he
comes back explaining the rules of
time-travel like there are some things
that you can mess with like I said
that's the key to getting tornado twins
you know messing with the timeline to
get even more comic book ease stuff down
the road but he goes off he's gonna go
find himself
I think he's appearing in at least three
episodes this year but Wally isn't on
legends anymore so he's effectively
leaving all the TV shows number two
ralph comes in makes a joke about the
continuity error from season one ralph
did need ID in the particle accelerator
explosion I still get a lot of questions
about that it's more of a continuity
error but the way the writers play it
off in this joke is that they blame
flashpoint there could be an alternate
timeline where I died in the particle
accelerator explosion so that's their
way of explaining about Ralph's didney
season one name-drop for all you asking
about that the bigger reveal though is
as the Caitlin's father faked his death
in the person that signed the death
certificate is actually icicle from the
comics the person that Ralph says signed
the death certificate
is Geor man ket that's the first version
of icicle from the comics meaning
they're kind of confirming that that's
who Caitlin's father's gonna be this
season and he'll be the key to bringing
killer frost back out number one of
course was that big was cicada at
the end where he kills all the metas you
don't see how he does it but they have
some cool special effects with his Speed
Force dagger in the way it's glowing
just seems like dark matter lightning so
I'm sure they'll have some fun way of
explaining how it's capable of killing
metas and taking away their powers
let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and I almost forgot when Nora joked
about King shark fighting Grodd they
actually are gonna do that later this
season in an episode I don't know which
number it's supposed to be but it might
be the second half of the season what'll
happen is is I'll do a trailer video for
episode 2 tomorrow morning leave all
your requests in the comments below I'm
sure everybody has a thousand questions
so I'll do bonus videos for whatever you
guys want I'll name the giveaway winner
when I post that next video click here
for that new venom carnage trailer and
click here to rewatch the flash season 5
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]